ومنا من اسطنبول الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي العقيد الركن حاتم كريم
الفلاحي اهلا بك معنا اذا في اليوم ال 105
من عمر هذه الحرب ما زالت المعارك ضاريه
ما زالت المقاومه تكبد الجيش الاسرائيلي
خسائر كبيره على الاقل حسب ما يظهر في
الفيديوهات والبيانات المنشوره من طرفها
كيف تفسر
ذلك نعم تحيه لكم ومشاهدين قناه الجزيره
نعم لا شك بان الحرب في المناطق المبنيه
تختلف عن الحرب في المناطق المفتوحه يضاف
الى ذلك بان عندما تكون الحروب بين جيوش
نظاميه ايضا تختلف عندما تكون الحروب مزيج
او هجين من من الانظمه من الانظمه
الهجوميه وبالتالي نحن نتكلم عن قوات
نظاميه بمواجهه قوات غير نظاميه وهذا يعني
بان هناك استراتيجيه غير مباشره لمواجهه
استراتيجيه مباشره بالنسبه للجيش الصهيوني
مثل هذه الحروب لا شك بانه لا يمكن ان
تكون هناك عمليه حسم سريعه وبالتالي ستبقى
مساله القال مستمره لفتره طويله خصوصا وان
المنطقه منطقه غزه يعني توجد فيها انفاق
هذه القضيه تساعد على عمل القطعات
المدافعه بشكل كبير جدا بحيث يمكن الظهور
خلف خطوط العدو او الظهور في مناطق لا
يتوقعها العدو او لا يتوقعها ويتفاجا فيها
القوات المقاتله هناك وبالتالي هذهه
القضيه تسبب ارباك كبير جدا بالنسبه
للقطعات خصوصا في المناطق التي تم التوغل
فيها وتم تطهيرها من قبل المهاجم ولكن
يتفاجا بعد فتره من الزمن واذا بالقوات
تظهر من هذه المناطق وتقوم بتنفيذ عمليات
على القطعات المتواجده هناك هذا يسبب
اشكال كبير جدا في منظومه القياده
والسيطره بالنسبه للقوات المهاجمه يضاف
الى ذلك بانها تنم على ان هناك منظومه
قياده وسيطره لدى المدافع تستطيع ان تقوم
بادوار دفاعيه مختلفه وهذا ما ما يعطي
دلال واضحه على ان القوات المتواجده في
هذه المنطقه خاصه في المنطقه الشماليه
انسحبت امام تقدم القوى الكبيره
والامكانيات والقدرات العسكريه من بعض
المناطق وهذا لا يعني بانها قد انتهت في
هذه المناطق وانما هي يمكن ان تعود للعمل
مره اخرى عندما تتوفر الظروف التعبويه
الملائمه للعمل الهجومي او او للعمل
الهجومي باتجاه القطاعات المدافعه وهذا ما
يحصل في الشمال فلذلك نرى بان العمليات
تشتد الان في الشمال على القطعات
المتواجده هناك خصوصا وان هناك عمليه سحب
لكثير من القطعات في هذه المناطق الامر
الذي ادى الى ارباك الخطط التعبويه
بالنسبه للمهاجم بشكل كبير جدا نعم يعني
هذه الحرب مستمره وعلى الاقل حسب ما يقوله
نتنياهو وحلفائه ربما تستمر حتى لاشهر
ماذا يعني هذا بالنسبه للمقاومه والحرب
تدور في منطقه محاصره بالكامل يعني حتى
الغذاء والماء والدواء لا يدخل غزه الا
بكميات قلي قيله
جدا نعم لا شك بان نتنياهو يراهن على عامل
الوقت خصوصا وان الجيش لم يستطع الى حد
هذه اللحظه ان ان ان ان ينفذ الاهداف التي
انطلقت من اجل هذه العمليه العسكريه لم
يتم لحد هذه اللحظه حسم هذه الاهداف
وبالتالي لابد للعمليه العسكريه من نظره
وجه سياسيه بالنسبه لنتنياهو بان تستمر
هذه العمليه العسكريه لكي يتم انجاز شيء
عسكري يمكن ان يقدم الى الشيء يقدم الى
الى الى الشعب او الى الجمهور في الداخل
لذلك هم يعملون بشكل كبير جدا على استمرار
هذه الحرب اما اذا جئنا على المعطيات
العسكريه نجد بان الاصوات الان تتعالى
بشكل كبير جدا من من قبل كثير من الخبراء
العسكريين الصهاينه الذين يقولون بان
الاستمرار في هذه المعركه هو اشكال كبير
جدا سيتسبب بارتفاع فاتوره الخسائر كما
انه سيؤثر على الروح القتاليه للجيش خصوصا
وان هناك جبهات اخرى هي ساخنه ايضا مثل
جبهه الضفه الغربيه والجبهه الشماليه وهذا
يعني بان الجيش اذا ما كانت هناك جبهه
اخرى مفتوحه لن يستطيع ان يقاتل على جبهات
متعدده وهذا الامر يضغط بشكل كبير جدا من
قبل القاده العسكريين على القاده
السياسيين للاستمرار في هذه العمليه التي
يظنون بان الاستمرار قد يعطيهم فرصه
للبقاء في السلطه لفتره اطول الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي العقيد الركن حاتم
كريم الفلاحي كنت معنا من اسطنبول شكرا
جزيلا l